damn that's her no that's britney spears
theo's comments on savannah just made me
recall this uh
looking fun
nice friend yeah i forgot i did that
dude i'm a fan
i'm with you on this man it was like
right before bed yeah
i bet it would bro okay i better get
pretty stinky after that comment
dude this lady
you guys you guys are being mean what
and here's what's interesting i could
see it happening bro thanks player damn
look at that hard-boiled somebody tried
to set us up one time
years ago yeah i used to know her cousin
when i was in college
come on man wait is she from new orleans
come on man that's like double d's is
she's a double g from one woman
she's from louisiana right deal you're a
strange guy man i love you
we're just saying come on man is she
from louisiana
yeah she's from kentwood louisiana bro
this is a match made in she has a
husband bro no she does if she's married
she's no she's married
she's not married anymore dude and if
she is i'll do a [ __ ] saving
silverman
and break him up for you i will do that
for you it could happen dude dude i want
you and britney spears to
be together dude i said i shot my
he said them yeah she's gonna see that
he's the top comment dude
hashtag free britney that's it what's in
front yams dude it's amazing you know
what i'm saying them freaking rip
nuggets baby them [ __ ] them sternum
hams though
hit me one more time dude
[Music]
is